and one of the suggestions that the
person had which really just you know
made me do a double take but then i
thought had some truth to it was that
what has replaced
uh religion for many americans is some
combination of political polarization
and even media tribes
where if you consume a certain
media's uh offerings then you you're
kind of joining a cult right and and you
know people refer to people who watch
certain channels that cult this cult
that but that really stuck with me yeah
david foster wallace the great american
writer one time said that everybody
worships something
because people are made to worship we're
just we're just worshipful creatures he
thought that was an innate feature of
humankind and if you take away something
that's worthy of worship you will
replace it with something that's
unworthy of worship it doesn't matter
who you are we all know intellectually
that politics is is unworthy of being
elevated to the level of religion and
yet this is i mean look
your campaign was related to trying to
to de-religiousize
and de-tribalize uh ideology of
political ideology in this country it's
like let's talk about how to to bring
people forward and understand each other
across ideological lines well that's
basically like going to people who are
extremely religiously fundamentalist and
say make common cause with this other
group of apostates and heretics you know
what we've done in this country and this
is one of the big problems that we have
is that people are worshiping at the
altar of american politics and their
preachers their tv preachers are on at 7
8 9 on cable channels
[Music]
this week on ford the author of from
strength to strength and columnist for
the atlantic on how to build a happy
life arthur brooks i'm so pumped for
this conversation this week on forward
it is my thrill to welcome to the
forward podcast kicking off his book
tour his 12th book
the best book from strength to strength
finding success
happiness and deep purpose in the second
half of life arthur brooks welcome
arthur thank you andrew what a delight
to be with you congratulations on this
great show thank you well greater for
your being here uh and i'm super pumped
so people may know you from your
incredibly popular comedy atlantic how
to build a life
uh you're also a harvard professor where
you teach
uh leadership and happiness is that
right at the harvard business school
yeah wow so those two things i would say
are in opposition to each other but
we'll come back to that
um you also have your own podcast how to
build a happy life right that people
love um i
will confess to you and this is
something you get all the time i'm an
avid consumer of your
writings of your work because anything
that makes you think that you might
somehow be able to live a better life
and be smarter about it yeah uh you know
you do so like i see your headlines in
the atlantic and i'm like click
that's great i mean it's really makes me
really happy to hear that um i mean the
prominence that you've had and the way
you've been able to live your dreams and
lift other people up through the power
of ideas good ideas that are supposed to
bring people together
i couldn't be happier to hear that
you're actually a consumer trying to use
what i'm doing and that's the point of
the column how to build a life in the
atlantic or what i'm teaching at the
harvard business school for that matter
this book you know when i i retired as a
ceo of a non-profit think tank and i
thought to myself when i was 55 years
old i didn't retire i mean i left the
position after 10 years i thought
what am i going to do the rest of my
life and i and i meditated about it i
thought about it i i talked to people i
really care about and i talked to the
dalai lama and asked him for his advice
yeah yeah we all do that you know
anytime we're at a decision point we
just just well he doesn't actually have
a cell phone
wait no no you don't use a cell phone
just close your eyes concentrate and
reach out to him or text him and and and
he said lift people up and bring them
together
and that's what i dedicated myself to
doing how do you do that by by talking
about what people care about the most
and people want to be happier people
need to be happier and to use intellect
to use ideas to to bring love and
happiness to other people's lives what a
joy to be able to do that yeah and and
you access the wisdom of the ages and
different cultures uh it's
awesome that
people have experienced this since the
beginning of time
you know they might have something to
say about it so i was joking with zach
and on the way in
um that reading this book kind of hit
home for me because i'm 47
and you talk about how uh people's fluid
intelligence may start to decline around
that time
so i was joking with zach that instead
of from strength to strength the book
should have been called how to decline
gracefully
it's actually the strength of strength
that's actually from the from the 84th
psalm and this is a and a blessing
in judaism to say uh
which is to say may you go from strength
to strength and but it comes from the
psalms and the whole idea is that look
we have strengths and they have a
cadence to them they have a life to them
and everything that goes up must come
down but there's another strength behind
it and this is one of the key things
that all of us have to learn i'm 57 i'm
10 years older than you are but this
book is written for people who are 27
like my students or 47 or 67 such that
the second half can be strong and happy
and graceful not in decline but in
finding the next strength and there
really is there is this
big agenda that lurks for everybody
behind the first source of strength if
we're courageous enough to look for it
if we're strong enough to go for it and
if we have enough faith to understand
and believe that it's actually there
yeah you talk about the two curves which
i thought was incredibly powerful so i
made the joke about the declining fluid
intelligence over your 30s 40s 50s which
is not entirely a joke i mean that's a
thing
which you point out early in your book
you're like hey
fyi
uh you may slow down in certain of your
skills or processes
um i'm just going to share a story
that's so nerdy and wonky but you'll
appreciate it all right third year is
better for me oh yeah so i ran
a test prep company called manhattan
prep for six years it became the biggest
company in the country yet getting
people to business school so if you were
to ask your harvard business school
students hey how many of you use
manhattan gmat like you know
a lot of them will put their hands up
we made our mark by hiring people who
scored 99th percentile on the gmat which
was at the time 760 or out of 800. so
here's the joke about declining skills
um
we asked people to get re-certified
every five years uh to go in and take
the gmat again and people totally did
not want to do it
because they'd gotten this they wanted
to watch it and they don't want to have
to do it again oh yeah no one does and
and i will say too as the ceo of the
company i completely understood where i
was like because i'd gotten a certain
score and it's like oh man i don't want
to go in there i'd like find out that
i've slowed down
oh for sure and this is a key thing my
son is a forward deployed combat marine
one of my sons and and every year he has
to get recertified as an expert marksman
and the first time he ever did it he
scored you know the top scorer he was an
expert he scored expert and the first
thing he said to me after he did is oh
it's great i feel great about it dad but
i got to do it again next year oh no so
once you hit that high water mark and so
you have to do it there's nothing worse
than than than than negative progress
than actually going in the wrong
direction this is what people really
fear more than anything else happiness
is in progress itself and here's the big
curse that actually comes for the
strivers and the people who are watching
your show are people like many
subscribers are strivers i mean they
want to do the most they want to take a
big bite out of life they are startup
lives not just startup businesses
because that's the essence of real
entrepreneurship is seeing your life as
your ultimate enterprise the problem is
that the more you do the more you strive
the more you achieve the higher you go
the more you notice it when it's not
there look if you never do anything in
your life how are you going to know when
you're not doing it anymore but the
higher you go the further you fall is
the whole point now that's really hard
on people and one of the things that i
found was that i always thought that you
if you if you made it if you did if you
were andrew yeah then you could cruise
then you'd be happy for the rest of your
life you'd be you know you when you're
you know 67 or 77 you'd be sitting there
you can always look back in that time i
ran for president a successful
entrepreneur you know i i i had a great
show i mean are you going to notch these
things on sort of the on the notches and
the belt and that's what you've got to
look back on but that's not the way it
is no no it's true the strivers struggle
more precisely because those things are
in the rearview mirror and they become
kind of addicted to the success after
success after success so number one is
we got to break the addiction but number
two is we have to find what the next
kind of success can be and that follows
the structure of the brain
you're at a particular age and and when
you're in your 30s you're really in your
prime but but you find that that that's
what you're saying i'm kidding
the horsepower that allows you to solve
problems incredibly quickly to do the
analysis to innovate that slows down for
everybody but there's this that's the
fluid intelligence yeah it's called
fluid intelligence this comes from the
work of raymond cattell social
psychologist in britain in the late 60s
and 70s but he says that there's a
second intelligence curve that that
increases when you're 47 that you're
getting better and better at that's your
wisdom curve or your crystallized
intelligence curve and you can do things
that you could never do before and you
can do them better and they're actually
more satisfying if you jump onto that
curve you figure out what you're
supposed to do with that curve the world
is your oyster and it's not even going
to decline all the way into old age that
is the promise of old age
yes and you see this arc let's say
uh in sports which you use in the book a
fair amount and the curve is shorter
because clearly
your physical prowess may max out in
your early 30s uh which is earlier than
it would be you know in most any other
arena
and then you see some athletes
transition to media
to coaching a lot of them become let's
say high school coaches
uh in their hometowns
and this is a natural
uh facet of growing crystallized
intelligence because it's what people
think of as wisdom more or less where
you can coalesce a set of experiences or
ideas and then
uh wrap them up in like a you know
a few pithy messages yeah that's right
to go from performer to teacher this is
the key you're really good at telling
about doing what other people tell you
to do the answer that for for those of
us who are in knowledge work for for
answering the questions that other
people pose to us faster better with you
know more innovative solutions so you're
the the brand new law associate in the
firm you can you can crack the case
faster than anybody else you can write
the code faster than anybody else i
could write you know early on in my
career as an academic i was doing this
sophisticated math modeling using early
artificial intelligence algorithms to
model public policy processes i can't
even read the math i was doing in those
days and and now on the second curve
which is the the instructor curve i'm
able to look at what other people are
doing and say i know the story that this
is telling together so i can write a
column now about happiness that i never
would have been able to write before so
i can take 15 people's research i can
translate it into the language that
humans can understand and put it
together in a story such that people can
read it and improve their lives with it
that's crystallized intelligence is
knowing the why knowing the sort of the
big picture of what's going on as
opposed to simply answering questions
more quickly and more innovatively than
other people
yeah and your columns do an excellent
job of that where you can tell you're
picking from different sources
or authors and then you distill it
now when i was reading your book i will
confess to having a complex set of
reactions
that's the idea yeah yeah i mean nobody
wants to say look a book that starts off
with
what goes up must come down and so if
you're really really cruising it's going
to come down you better be ready and get
on the next curve so you can go up and
stay high but nobody wants to know that
they're going to decline but i got to
take a two by four to the chop so the
readers at the very beginning to get
their attention yeah and you talk about
how even in person when you say this to
a ceo they're like oh that's not me
because i'm just going to keep on
freaking speeding along until the wheels
come off totally it's like it's like
it's like work work work croak that's
like the ceo model in new york we're
sitting here in new york city and that's
the the finance
hedge fund king model is work till you
die
and the truth is you're
you're gonna decline and that's normal
it's actually a good thing because it's
your signal like you're an entrepreneur
and you're a successful entrepreneur one
of the things that entrepreneurs have in
common is that where everybody else sees
a problem they see an opportunity that's
the key aspect of the entrepreneurial
orientation where even dumb things like
man there's no good bars and restaurants
in this neighborhood the entrepreneur's
like
i'm going to open a bar
or solve that problem yeah
that's an opportunity but that's a good
thing it's an exciting thing and that's
how we have to see our lives when you
see something declining in your in your
ability to solve a problem quickly this
is not failure this is opportunity to
move to the next thing and the next
thing is for you to become you got to go
from kind of your elon musk brain to
your dalai lama brain and every one of
us can do that if we cultivate it and
this is a how-to guide on how to
cultivate that second phase
[Music]
if you know me you know that i think
that your data should be yours and not
the big tech companies who just hoover
it on up and they take and they take and
what do you get back in return uh
agitation
many questions but they also are selling
your data uh and profiteering and that's
not the way you should be surfing the
web or using the internet i recommend
using a virtual private network and the
vpn we recommend here at forward is
expressvpn
it's the number one rated vpn provider
huge firms use it
i use it you should use it visit
expressvpn.com
yang to get three months free on a one
year package that's e x p r e s s
vpn dot com slash yang to learn more
you'll be glad you did you can just surf
anonymously know that the tech companies
can't keep track of you
what is peace of mind worth uh you know
it'll just make you sleep easier surf
easier and know that no one's keeping
track of you because you're beaming in
through some server in some far off
place that is completely anonymous
expressvpn.com
[Music]
uh so i'm going to share a little bit of
my personal experience uh running for
president in the aftermath so i decided
like you're like every man it's like
for president then it's after math
because it is very much tied to some of
the the things you say in the book and
that that's one of the reasons i had a
complex set of reactions honestly
[Laughter]
so
um so i decided to run
in early 2017 after trump won and i was
like okay things are not going well
maybe i i can do something about this
uh and then
declare in 2018 and i become
completely single-minded for the next
two plus years right where i joke with
people that i had two goals one
accelerate the end of poverty uh in
america and stay married and those are
my two goals
[Laughter]
by twin
north stars
uh and i had this
ambition and vision where i said you
know what if i run for president to the
best of my ability and people get behind
me i believe i can meaningfully
advance the human condition right our
understanding of what's happening to us
economically and socially and the fact
that
we do live in an era of potential
abundance instead of just imposing
scarcity on so many people in my mind
artificially and unnecessarily
so the campaign ends
uh i suspend it in the beginning of 2020
i come off the trail and at the end of
my campaign i was like this super
powered gladiatorial figure you know
showing up and seventh national debate
and just you know at this point like you
know yeah you you feel
familiar with things that would have
been completely unfamiliar right not
that long ago and i come off
and there's a significant part of me
that was like okay
um at this point
i should be pretty happy with my
career or impact because
if you can die tomorrow and then it
could say on your tombstone or an
epitaph like hey this guy helped advance
the universal basic game cup or
something like that um that's pretty
good
that was like you know like a fair
fairly
uh good high-water mark but then you
wake up the next day and you're like
okay i'm still here
uh there's still a lot of
need a lot of problems like what do i do
next and there was this side of me too
arthur where i went from being a
completely anonymous
figure circa 2018 to being quite well
known by 2020 right
and i'm not someone who's a natural
extrovert like it wasn't something where
i was like ooh my goal is to be famous
or am i going to be president like i
really
didn't care i don't really want people
that have that as their main ambition
there's a problem with the
self-selection effect into american
politics it's one of the reasons you
were so refreshing is because clearly
your ambition was not to be a famous guy
or president united states it was
clearly to make progress in public
policy and to help people's lives that
was the overarching ambition and that
was the allure that was the reason that
so many of us are like finally well
thank you for seeing that and so totally
no that was quite evident i'm so glad so
i felt that uh and but then i found
myself in this really odd position where
it's like okay now i'm famous now i
might be able to try and do something
positive like what am i gonna do with it
so i spent 20 2020
campaigning for joe
and in georgia trying to help the
democrats win the senate and then i came
back and was like i'm gonna run for
mayor of new york city because i think i
can i can do good
and
there's been this personal struggle i've
had when i was reading this
uh description of the striver's curse
and i was talking to my wife about it
this morning before coming to the studio
and i said you know i've been very much
an achiever right like i haven't
measured my achievement in
money or some other things
um i've been trying to have as positive
and impact as i could
in the time that i have and i still
am trying to do that and so when you
were characterizing
uh the the striver's curse and the the
fact that at a certain point you want
different things like it it did evoke a
set of reactions in me because
i have felt myself
struggling with whether i'm supposed to
maintain
uh
for example like this public facing
persona post the presidential campaign
whereas before this i was a ceo so
there's part of me it's like hey maybe i
should like you know go find an
operation
like build it yeah um uh and so there
and one of the things i pride myself on
is this adaptation um you talk about
yeah um and so it's been an interesting
journey for me for sure um over this
past number of months
but one of the things you do suggest
fairly strongly i thought toward the end
of the book
is for someone to make a professional
transition yes and you suggest that it's
something of a leap of faith it
absolutely is look
nobody
there's no guarantee that the next thing
you're going to do is going to be
successful there was no guarantee it was
going to be successful being president
united states you're run for prison
united states
except that
it wound up being very successful
because what's the point look if you're
an idea person that's trying to change
the agenda then then
winning a presidential campaign the odds
are very low of that but a presidential
campaign per se is a huge megaphone to
get ideas into the public sphere you
were a missionary now i've had a lot of
missionaries on both sides of my family
and the weird thing is that they get
constant rejection and they always lose
and yet they're happy the reason they're
happy i like that equation no i mean
it's like you know words that no human
has ever uttered before are oh good
there's missionaries on the porch i mean
nobody has ever said those words right i
mean they're constantly getting the door
slammed in their face but they're filled
with joy because they're bringing light
where there's darkness they're bringing
what they believe to be truth where
there is falsehood or where there is
ignorance and this is the point of what
you were trying to do you were that you
took the public spotlight you said this
is a blessing to be in the public
spotlight notwithstanding what actually
happens in the democratic primary i'm
going to try to help solve these
problems by injecting the ideas to solve
these problems that doesn't have to stop
with a presidential campaign stopping
and indeed it didn't because you were
still very well known on the campaign
trail and then running for mayor and now
doing the show this is a kind of a
moving feast of ideas you're trying to
onboard these particular ideas and this
is what we need to do look we all have a
moral mission we all have a reason for
existing to again to lift people up and
bring them together in our own way and
when the first set of skills when that
that we actually were gifted
we use them to the max and when those
things are not the right gift we have to
look for new gifts for new opportunities
the point is not winning a particular
race
the point is actually advancing the
cause of progress whatever that happens
to mean for each of our lives and at the
beginning that might be innovation which
it was for you as an entrepreneur later
on it might be teaching which actually
it was for you as a presidential
candidate i watched your speeches you're
a professor you were saying here's a
here's the thing i was joking with you
and you came in that being an academic
is the family business yeah
my brother my father my uncle my
grandfather all phds and professors yeah
so i've always been kind of the
commercially oriented educational rent
of the litter
that's like yeah no andrew got really
really rich but you know he turned out a
phd so
it's i don't know where we went wrong
when i was a little kid i would ask boys
in school or girls in school whoever
like go you know what is your dad's phd
in yeah because my dad had a phd so i
imagined everyone's dad had a phd of
course the lesson i learned was that
that was not the right question to ask
it
pretty quickly
yeah so yeah no that's right so i think
and each person watching us by the way
all the strivers watching us they're
watching your show because
they think it's interesting and you have
guests that they that have something to
say and they're interested in you and
they're just in the gestalt of this
which is a very kind of ideas oriented
progress culture
they have to understand that their life
is a is a vehicle their life is a
platform for creating value the way
you're going to create value is not
going to stay the same all the way
through your life because your abilities
are going to change but your dedication
to progress and value shouldn't so go
with the flow man that's basically what
i'm saying you're going to get better
and better and better and then things
are going to get harder on the first
curve the second curve where you
actually become
the sage where you actually become the
professor whatever that means as a
mentor as a teacher as a helper as
somebody who's actually going there's
also the entrepreneurs curve we talked
about athletes it's very very analogous
yeah so the entrepreneurs the founder
ceo which by the way is an incredible
grind
it's like
16 hour days i mean it's crazy yeah you
just have to like i joke that it's a bit
like parenting um where your business is
like a
set of grenades and you just like jump
on the grenade all day and then you get
up and then oh there's another one you
jump on that child rearing similar so
when you're the founder and ceo uh
you're just jumping on grenades all the
time and working your your tail off um
and then maybe you do that
twice
maybe three times and then if you have
some success uh and you're very
fortunate you have a lot of excellent
people around you you end up being an
investor right or an advisor or and i i
had a call
last week with a friend who resembles
this where he's a serial entrepreneur
and an inventor and then he said i've
gone to the dark side i've become a
venture capitalist
which is what what happens when you're
not going to be the founder operator and
so then you wind up advising a bunch of
younger youths
yeah what you have is pattern
recognition at that point what what
older people have crystallized
intelligence is about pattern
recognition you're able to see what's
going on you have a sixth sense about
what's going on because you have a ton
of data and you're able to describe
what's happening that's the reason that
older people are better at building
teams they're better at directing other
people they're better at teaching other
people what they ought to be looking out
for so somebody who's older is going to
be better in vc and somebody who's
younger is better at being an operator
of an entrepreneurial firm and we all
have kind of the equivalent of that
whether we're doing data entry or
whatever it happens to be you could be a
hot analytic lawyer early on and a
managing partner later on but the key
thing is to remember that your skills
are going to change and you shouldn't
fear it it's a good it's a different
axis or exactly right
we need to be preparing for that you
know when people who are 25 or 35 who
are watching us and a lot of your
audience of course is of different ages
and young people saying well that's way
off for me well you got to set the you
got to set you could do the groundwork
now to get ready to be to be creating
value all the way over the course of
your life and to be comfortable with the
change that's going to be happening in
each one of us and there's a whole bunch
of things to do and so this is basically
a you know a 10-step
game plan i wrote it for me by the way i
didn't intend to pull it it was very it
was very personal and it was clearly uh
something that you were digging through
yourself yeah i mean i stepped down as a
ceo because i did the research for this
this was a this is me search not
research and i was in the middle of my
career as an executive that
it was going great i mean it was i was
working adl you can tell us the truth
arthur
there was a skeleton that was bad i'm
kidding
this was a negotiated settlement no and
it was
it was going really well on his face but
i could see you know i was looking at
other people that were in the job i
wanted to be like jordan and go out on
top man
and then come back
and it was interesting because
looking at it i knew
that there i had more
i had more value to create but i knew
that my skills were going to change on
the basis of this research you know when
you're a social scientist
and you you actually set your own
cooking man in china i was like i'm more
like taking out my own appendix it was
you know this was an eight-year research
project so that i could create a
strategic plan for my happiness for the
rest of my life which i started when i
was 48 years old wow and and i i did the
research and i got i was halfway through
the research and and i decided i needed
to leave my job wow i quit my job
because of my own research and i went
back to academia i quit my political
party because of my own research
but continue did you quit your political
party yeah you're not a democrat no
you're an independent yeah me too
oh wow look at that
yeah
um so getting an independent before it
was cool you definitely yeah it was a
long time i've been for 15 years i've
been an independent yeah and uh the
think tank you ran was i'd consider it
centrist independent yeah very
independent um very free or enterprise
oriented around the american enterprise
oh wait someone here is going to yell at
me and be like they're not
because this is a polarized time you
know people are going to yell at me
because i love andrew yang but you know
look the truth of the matter is you've
got to find truth where it exists and
you have to make common cause with
people who share your values if we look
i believe in progress you believe in
progress i believe there's a better
future ahead of us i believe the world
is better than it used to be but it can
be better still
and you know that kind of optimism and
hope may not be hip right now but that's
the future that's the only future we've
got if we're going to have a future
that's worth anything you're a very very
consistent source of uplift man i mean
it's it's fun i think you and i might
share that comment too because i do
have uh like some
feeling that other people are looking to
me to be upbeat and stay upbeat which
you know and this is one of the things i
was going to joke with you about is like
let's say you go into someone's office
and they're a personal trainer
um they better be in good shape you know
what i mean
it's absolutely true because and part of
it is
it's okay if you're not there yet but
you have to be on the path yeah this is
the important thing it's okay to to not
be perfect if you're if you're a
therapist it's okay if you're neurotic
but you have to be working to get better
you know you don't you don't want a
marriage counselor who's who's cheating
on his wife that's not what you want
because that's the that's that shows
somebody's hypocritical and actually
doesn't believe what they're saying but
in your case you would need to be at
least marginally upbeat for me to buy
that you should be talking about how to
be happy yeah
the change that i made when i stepped
down as an executive when i stepped down
from a cheap executive job that required
huge amounts of fluid intelligence and
went to a pure crystallized intelligence
career so what i'm doing now is i'm
sharing ideas
at the university in my column in books
i do speeches every week all of when i'm
talking about ideas
i'm in crystallized list i'm truly just
as the data would suggest i'm much
happier than i was and i'm getting
happier
[Music]
it's the winter time it's kind of gray
out there unless you are a very bizarre
soul you might be feeling a little bit
down and sometimes when you're down you
know it's going to pass but sometimes
you should really talk to someone and i
don't mean that friend that just grunts
at you i mean someone who actually is
professional and trained and can dig
into
whatever depression or stress or
relationship issues you are having and
that's why i am so proud to be sponsored
by better help
better help is helping millions of
people take charge of their mental
health by connecting them
you to a professional
mental health resource therapist someone
who actually can dig into your issues
and get you feeling better about your
life hence the name better help
i want you to be healthy
vibrant enjoying all of the things that
you should be appreciating and as a
listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
yang join over one million people who've
taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help help
dot com slash yang you'll be glad you
did get some help
[Music]
so you made this relatively dramatic
career shift uh and it sounds like that
there were some
real uncertainties and some difficulties
making the transition yeah well or i've
actually had four distinct careers i've
radically changed i mean early on i was
a classical musician so
i left college at 19 at the request of
the college i was i was invited that
kicked out why well you know it turns
out that i was playing that french horn
too loud yeah i didn't exactly get
kicked out it was a negotiated
settlement we um i had i had dropped all
my required classes and was taking north
indian classical drumming and indonesian
dance instead which you know
you know sticklers
it turns out that that's that's not that
you know the way to to meet your
requirements and so i left and i went on
the road now that now that school's
trying to take credit for you right
my guess is my records have been
expunged at this point but
i was i was uh playing the french horn
in in chamber music and then and then in
the barcelona symphony for a bunch of
years uh and so that's where all i
wanted to do talk about a career that
will run its course
if you look at a professional dancer or
a professional musician i mean a lot of
that
declines some classical musicians can go
on a lot longer but you find that the
best
usually the prime for classical
musicians is mid-30s is what we find
just because it uses fine motor skills i
peaked at 22. and i don't know why and
it was a real source of heartache for me
that at 22 i was doing my best playing
and i just wasn't playing as well after
that and things that had been easy
became hard and and it was weird because
i was i had more experience and i was
practicing you're such a veteran curve
hopper totally yeah so i hopped curves
by at 31
um i left i did my bachelor's degree by
distance learning
finished that a month before my 30th
birthday and then went to graduate
school started my phd and did that when
i finished that in my mid-30s and then
became an academic so listening to this
you think it's too late to go get your
degree
do do something different i mean arthur
would say different do it do it i mean
i've taken my career literally no
literally because that's this is a
metaphor metaphorically taken my career
down to the studs four times wow you
know from classical musician to
economist
to ceo and now as running this happiness
enterprise and their professor happiness
it's it's it beats working
professor
human wisdom
it's really fun and good and it's the
right thing at the right time and each
person watching us we we genuinely
badly badly needed a professor of human
wisdom uh truly like i feel like you
actually filled this massive need it's
so fun it's so great i couldn't have
done it when i was 35 is the whole point
but then of course there's there's the
the natural fear that people have the
natural tendency that people have to to
regret
stopping doing something that they're
already really good at because it feels
like you're squandering the capital that
you've built totally
this is i'm going to share this with
people now i'm going to make make people
feel but but it's
so i started on social media because i
was running for president right you
could look it up it's like before i ran
for president
i was not there six thousand followers
yeah whatever yeah uh but and then now
you know i have several million across
platforms and so you cannot look at that
and be like well let's just you know
stop or whatever yeah um meanwhile i'm
friends with dave chappelle
um and the man is not on any social
media
you sit there talking to him you're
looking at him um he is in my opinion
also a very very wise human like you um
but i i felt like his wisdom was in part
because he just managed to freaking skip
the entire social media thing some
people can do that and right now it's
actually hard to do that because the
communication mechanisms they they don't
require that but that's one of the ways
that people ordinarily reach the public
yes like no one would advise some
aspiring entertainer like hey it's you
social media but you know that that's
something that um might be good advice
honestly will you be happier absolutely
i mean the the data are abundantly clear
that at very least turn off your
notifications if you're if you're in the
public eye at all and people are
following you you should you should not
be looking at your notifications because
it's an anonymous zone of polarization
and hatred i mean social media is a
contempt machine
it's a real problem and so if you're
going to use it use it like a tool you
know don't be you know looking at the
tool over and over again and obsessing
on the tool over and over and over again
i mean the way that you can get into a
celebrity's head is tweet about them and
that you know that that famous
famous celebrity's got three million
followers is probably reading your tweet
on her couch
well the so there's uh an nba player
who's sort of famous for this uh kevin
durant who someone will say something
nasty about him and then he'll just come
in
you know a friend of mine a friend of
mine who's got a huge uh social media
following he says that every you know he
he he always succumbs to the temptation
to get into a twitter war and what he
wants is to create he's an inventor like
he's an entrepreneur like you and he
wants to create a a device that will
automatically give him a hundred volt
shock every time he answers somebody on
twitter so they'll get aversion therapy
to doing that because there's there's no
upside to it there's no upside there
absolutely isn't because all you're
doing is somebody's punching up because
they want to get something i can't tell
you how many times
i've seen a tweet
and then thought about responding and
then realized that by responding to it
uh i would do two things i would not
want to do number one is i'm going to
end up uh augmenting the attention paid
to whatever the heck like right now that
person probably no one saw it um and so
by replying to it all of a sudden the
spotlight goes on right uh number two
i'm going to be fueling
uh this notion that uh hey
one way to stick it to andrew would be
to write something because he clearly
sees it
you can get in andrew's head andrew's
head you know so so my friend neil
ferguson he sometimes says that that he
wouldn't
if he wouldn't let um somebody into his
living room he shouldn't let them into
his brain
and this is kind of good advice for
everybody so he doesn't read his
notifications he's a really well-known
guy he's on he has a lot of social media
followers he's an important public
intellectual but he's controversial
sometimes and so people are kind of
going after him and this is the culture
that we're i mean like this is what you
were campaigning against for president
was this this this culture of
polarization this culture of tribalism
of of uh us versus them so we can't
those of us that are dedicated to
fighting against that we can't fall prey
to it my my ministry my apostolate is
bringing people together and lifting
them up that the idea of happiness and
love is what i'm going to do for the
rest of my life it's inconsistent with
that mission for me to write a nasty
tweet
yes
wow elevating the human condition
um so there there is
something you write about in the book
that's related to your unconventional
background the fact that you've started
over a few times that you're the head of
the think tank and then people were
arguing over whether you could provide a
quality education uh to people for 10
000 or less and they were like oh you
can't do it because obviously you know
it cost 200 000 to provide a quality
education
and then you came out and said hey look
i'm the head of a fancy think tank and i
had a very uh scrappy unusual low-cost
college education 10 grand soup to nuts
including the books including the
sticker for the car which i didn't put
on the car
it was um and it was incredible it
changed my life you know when i was
doing my bachelor's degree by distance
learning
i didn't have the money to pursue a
bachelor's degree i was a musician i
didn't even have health insurance
for a lot of that time it was tough but
it had had it not been for entrepreneurs
that we're trying to find a new way for
people to do an old thing which is what
entrepreneurs are all about god bless
america i mean there's no other place in
the world where i would have been able
to do this i wouldn't have had a
bachelor's degree so i wouldn't have had
a master's degree and a phd and change
career so many schools trying to take
credit for you now arthur
i've been very lucky and i've been very
very lucky i have to say also i had good
parents that that gave me a lot of
confidence i could do these things but
the reason i wrote this book is because
everybody has a trajectory of greatness
in the realm in which they have gifts
but they can't be stuck on their old
skills they can't be stuck in the past
they got to be ready to jump and to be
thinking about
what they can do to lift other people up
what they can do that is that is their
greatness and and do it in a way that
that their that their time of life
actually
makes it easiest and makes it best
so the data shows that a couple things
will help preserve your happiness into a
long life particularly loving
relationships romantic relationships and
also
real friendships and there is this
person who distinguished
uh for you between real friends and deal
friends yeah uh like the friends that
you exchange transactions with uh either
professional or otherwise and then the
friends that
uh will be
with you through thick and thin even
uh you know if there's nothing in it for
them right uh that sort of thing useless
friends that's the key thing it's
interesting so so aristotle talked about
the difference between telic and atelic
activities and that meant italic means
uh not good for something else just just
intrinsically beautiful and fun in
themselves the reason that people love
baseball is because not because baseball
helps their career in any way but
because precisely the people reason why
people love baseball is because it's so
devoid of anybody it's so devoid of any
professional you know it's like it's not
it's not instrumental and we love the
intrinsic things not the instrumental
things well the same thing is true with
people we need people around us we need
friends who are
in a weird way useless not worthless
i've known tons of worthless people that
i love too but that useless friends you
know we have too many useful people in
our lives and it has to do with the fact
that we
we we incorrect we have this incorrect
uh formula for living and this is one of
the things i talk about if you want to
get older better and happier you got to
get your formula right then the formula
that people tend to follow is is use
people love things and worship yourself
that's what people do and it's
completely wrong it's not it's actually
not the path to enlightenment it's close
enough to write actually that it sounds
right because the verbs and the nouns
are messed up the right formula is love
people only use things only and worship
the divine whatever that means for you
only and then things are in order then
you've got your your sort of happiness
hygiene on point and then you can
actually proceed with your life and and
and see yourself in the dignity which
you should have
arthur brooks advice don't use people
but this is what useful friends kind of
are and i don't mean that we're you know
we're using them etc etc but if
everybody in your rolodex is a deal
friend
and and the people you're talking about
are not your real friends i have this
really close friend that i've had for
many years he's in atlanta
and uh
he's somebody that
sometimes i work with him and sometimes
i don't
but i just look forward to talking to
him i talk to him a couple of times a
week on the telephone we make time now a
couple times a week i mean that's a
freaking she's my friend i love him i
love him i can't i'm super interested in
what's going on with his family and his
grandchildren and and he's he knows my
family and he came up from atlanta for
my birthday and it's just
and it's just it's such a source of
value to me because it's not useful to
me
and and he could be useful to me i mean
he's a very super successful
entrepreneur he's like you
and yet that's not the thing that i
really really love and everybody needs
one of the things that you need to get
from your first curve your second curve
is more loving relationships and that
means
companionate love on the romantic side
but it also means real friends not deal
friends and what a lot of people have
when they're when they're stuck on that
first curve and raging against changes
in their in their abilities is they got
nobody to call they have nobody to help
them they have nobody who cares and
loves them enough
through thick and thin to not think less
of them you know we're really worried
about what people around us think if
we're you know stepping back from the
greatness stepping back from the
limelight or we're seeing if we're
missing a step
then people say like i don't know what's
going on with andrew you know see see
him at that meeting he's like i don't
feel like he even read his briefings i
don't know what the dealio is
and as opposed to your friend who's like
who cares hey what's going on with your
wife what's going on with your kids
friends don't judge that bad meeting
[Laughter]
you know presidential debate if it's if
it's something that's really really
splashy and fancy like in your case but
all of us have a oh man i got so many
texts after each presidential debate
which you don't read
i've read some of them um
[Laughter]
um so i
reflected on uh my real friends and deal
friends yeah as you suggested it it was
an interesting exercise for me
but i love the idea of having friends
that aren't useful
um because you everyone i think knows
what i'm talking about or you're talking
about there where you're friends because
you're friends totally and you know if
he if he or she becomes poor you're
still friends and and if they move to a
different state you're still friends if
they leave the industry and can't help
you anymore you're still friends and and
you got to have that there's no other
way
[Music]
i have a habit
um that i'd like to share though i think
is a good one
um
when a friend has a set and this
actually there's gonna be you know this
is a relatively recent development
because i've become a public figure and
so i i know other public figures but
whenever anyone's going through
something shitty
and i find out about it i just send them
a private message being like hey you
know keep your head up it's going to be
fine
because i just know that they they feel
like all this stuff coming at them
uh and i just want them to remember that
it's nonsense for sure you know what
that's a really good thing it's one of
the things i teach in my class at
harvard that we have a tendency to think
that that the bad feelings that we get
that are provoked by a bad event that is
permanent because that's the way our our
mind wants us you know if a tiger's
chasing you you want in that moment to
think that tiger's gonna be chasing me
forever and so you you muster all of
your energy to get away but the truth of
the matter is that your brain the bad
feelings are going to dissipate that's a
phenomenon called homeostasis you will
go back to equilibrium you just don't
know it in that moment and it's very
very important i mean sooner or later
your friend is going through a tough
time got fired business went under they
got a really horrible article about them
in the new york times whatever it
happens to be or on a smaller scale you
know that their
something happens those are pretty much
the types of things i'm talking about
and and so they're gonna feel better but
when you when andrew writes a text
saying it's gonna be okay keep your head
up trust me this is a this is a one-week
story yeah what you've done is you've
accelerated the homeostasis of those bad
feelings for that person you can
literally
help somebody's basic negative emotions
to dissipate you can you can you can you
can affect the neural circuitry of your
friend by simply sending a text saying
trust me this is a one-week story you
know so i want to confess something else
this is a little bit of insight into uh
into the life of someone who's in the
public eye so occasionally i received
those messages from friends being like
hey you know it's gonna be fine and then
my reaction is actually mixed because
i'm like oh [ __ ] i guess they like they
saw that like i guess it must have been
really bad yeah exactly like i guess
they saw that freaking thing that i was
like yeah no one's gonna see that yeah
and then you get a bunch of text you're
like oh i guess people did see that yeah
yeah um so when i send these texts it's
from something objectively like i could
not have missed yeah for sure you know
it's interesting that i i you know that
actually happened to me when i was first
the ceo in washington running this think
tank at the at the center of political
controversy and i handled something
publicly really wrong and i got just i
just got barbecued in the washington
post and you know a bunch of i just
didn't handle it very well
and uh and and i was feeling horrible
like this is going to dog me forever
yeah catastrophized which is a real
cognitive problem that people do you
know something goes wrong like this is
gonna be horrible forever i thought this
is gonna dog me for my whole career this
is it i failed it's gonna be out
it's gonna be written on my time
you know human resource issues or you
know whatever it is and and my neighbor
across the street was this grizzled
washington veteran i lived in bethesda
at the time and he has been hit this guy
had been through the wars a hundred
times and he said so i saw in the paper
and i'm like oh you saw in the paper he
says you know
i deal with crises all the time on a
scale of zero to ten in severity this is
a .025
wow that's so nice to hear and it was at
first i thought you know this sob is
minimizing my pain and i thought no no
actually he's he quite objectively he's
assessing the severity of this problem
and he's helped he helped me get back on
you know homeostatically getting back to
a kind of an emotional equilibrium and
so the key thing for us all to remember
is when bad things are happening not
going to last on the other hand andrew
when good things happen they're not
gonna last either and one of the things
one of the parts of the striver's curse
that i talked about in this book
is that you know one of the things that
a lot of people watching us they have
they might not be have an alcohol use
disorder or be addicted to drugs but
they're success addicts and one of the
things that success brings you
professionally and socially
is that it gives you a hit of dopamine
in your brain and you you become an
addict for that you want the success hit
again and again and again and the reason
you're never satisfied the reason that
it's so hard when you achieve something
and you're off that mark is because
you're in true deficit dopamine deficit
and that's excruciating the reason for
that it doesn't last is the same reason
that your bad feelings don't last
because your brain has to go back to its
equilibrium it's got to go back to its
baseline and that's one of the things
that we have to remember as well you
can't
through more and more and more and more
success actually attain this you need to
find a better more sustainable curve
yeah well and furthermore you need to
manage not just your halves you need to
manage your wants yeah you need to want
one of the one of the great sources of
consequences would you rather be special
or happy that's one of the questions i
asked in the book and you know as i'm
interviewing this lady for the book and
she was a
wall street titan
and uh and she knows how it is i'm just
kidding
i'll take it to my grave i mean i don't
divulge any identities in this book
because some of the stuff is so
sensitive but you know this this woman
who
has had an incredible career in wall
street but she's noticing that she's
sort of starting to miss a beat and
there are a lot of things in her life
that she doesn't like and i said well
step back you know work on your marriage
and your relationship with your adult
kids and and stop drinking and get into
the gym and and don't worry about work
so much you know you've got all the
money you could ever need why do you
keep doing this and she said
you know
i think i'd prefer to be special than
happy
and i thought to myself that's pretty
common that's the success addict's
anthem
they prefer to be special than happy
because special gives you the hit gives
you the hit you know perfectly if
there's no heroin addict on the planet
that thinks they're finally going to
have had enough heroin
there's no alcoholic who thinks so i'm
just going to have three more bottles
and i'm going to be i'm like i'm going
to stop spontaneously because i'm not
going to need it anymore they just
prefer to be high than happy and this is
what we do a lot you can't get to your
second curve unless you unless you get
off that that wheel that hamster wheel
of hit hit hit success success having
better wants you know one rule of thumb
i'm taking from this conversation
i think people should take to heart
what's that visit
one friend per year for their birthday
yeah
oh yeah no no it's it's an astonishing
thing you're never sorry you did that
you you think uh can i afford to do it
dude the time i'm so busy
i'm so busy
i know but it's so true you know and
it's it's you know all the things that i
remember
it's incredible you know um i remember
one time i was debating you know whether
or not to go to a friend's house
for dinner
because i'm so busy i just didn't really
have time and and i went anyway and i'm
like ah this is gonna be really late
and i don't remember anything about what
i was doing what i was so stressed out
about but that night we were
we had dinner it was in in maryland and
up on on the severn river which is a
beautiful place and it was it was at
dusk
and he's this friend of mine he said i
want you to see this thing and he took
me out to his garden and there was this
flower and all the flowers were closed
it was dusk all the flowers were closed
he says watch a flower i'm like what
said what watch the flower i'm like okay
and 10 minutes later it suddenly
opened just spontaneous like
the and they all opened at the same time
surely they pop open at dusk and i was
like
and i remember that i'm gonna remember
that it was intensely satisfying to
remember that for the rest of my life
i'm not gonna remember the work that i
for went that evening that was the
evening of the flower and this if you go
to your friend's birthday if you if you
do something that's meaningful you know
if you look at something if you if you
if you narrow cast into the beauty that
is the little things in life
then you'll get the intense satisfaction
that you actually seek but sitting on
that treadmill
hit hit hit you're never going to get
enough dopamine that you're going to be
ultimately satisfied
one fascinating tidbit in your book was
that apparently the loneliest
professions
are doctor and lawyer yeah uh and so i i
wanted to dig into that a little bit
though i did remember because i was an
attorney in a past life for five months
and you went to law school for three
years and then you practiced as a lawyer
for five months yeah that's right my
asian parents were very pleased
they were very pleased for five months
no no they're they'll be they were
pretty pretty sad but
um
are you kidding i didn't go to college
till i was 30. i had a gap decade
imagine how fun that was for my
professor parents wow
so parents take it easy you're guys
everything can turn out okay
i do remember reading at the time that
lawyers had the highest average alcohol
consumption of any profession yeah um
but this spoke to this striver's curse
you
write about um in large part because
apparently a lot of high achievers
self-medicate via alcohol they do
according to oacd as a matter of fact
alcohol use disorder is predominates
among people with high socioeconomic
status in the united states especially
among men which is not the stereotype
nope no we think about people who are
down and out as getting drunk and the
people who are using alcohol to blunt
anxiety to make it possible to unwind to
get the machine off is actually more
common for for strivers than it is for
people who are not strivers now that the
truth is that addiction is a very funny
thing we tend to become addicted to the
to the thing that self-medicates us for
our particular melody and so you find
for example that that that kids
adolescents who are struggling to focus
who have maybe some attention deficit
issues but it's it's unremediated they
tend they're way more likely to get
addicted to nicotine you know they're
way more likely to start smoking at 13
or 14 because nicotine is an
unbelievably effective add or adhd drug
it brings it it draws it sucks dopamine
into the prefrontal cortex and allows
you to focus
so the same thing is true if you have a
lot of stress you have a lot of anxiety
you have a lot a lot of trouble making
the world slow down because you're such
a striver
alcohol is incredibly effective at
turning the switch on that the problem
is it's a messy drug and it's a
dangerous drug there's a lot of data
that show that you know that one of the
biggest reasons that people wind up
getting unhappier as they get older is
precisely because of alcohol use the
alcohol is not because of the happiness
problems the causality runs in the other
direction alcohol is a really dangerous
thing that we have and for everybody
watching us you know so one of the
things i talk about in this book is if
you want to grow old well you want to
get on that second curve you want to age
gracefully you look at your alcohol use
and look at your substance use but the
maybe the most dangerous substance of
all for the strivers is the success
addiction
this idea the self-objectification where
i'm an effective person i'm i'm i'm
going to make it's it's weird and we all
fall prey to this my father died a long
time ago i mean my father died in 2002
when he was pretty young
and i still think all the time wonder if
he'd be wonder if he'd be proud of me i
wonder if he'd be proud of this book
what if my dad read this book why do you
think this but we tend to we're very
tied to the expectations even of long
dead relatives and for strivers where
those where that that that level of
expectation is sky high it's very easy
to turn into a workaholic it's very easy
to turn into a success addict and that's
a tyranny
[Music]
i i will say i somehow liberated myself
from the parental expectation thing some
time ago because check it out so i
so i leave the uh legal field they're
very sad and then they just lie and tell
my friends i'm a lawyer for a number of
years i'm still a lawyer technically
this is true
um so then i i'm a part of some failed
startups uh then i become ceo of an
education company eventually i decided
to run for president my parents are
completely negative on that decision
when i tell them a disreputable decision
yeah and now with one just a sidebar i
go around uh trying to encourage
people from
um traditionally a political backgrounds
to get more involved including asian
americans and i tell them all the times
like look i get it i grew up in a
household where my parents never talked
about american politics did not get the
message they're immigrants right yeah
they're immigrants from uh taiwan from
taiwan um from and originally from the
mainland uh no they actually grew up in
taiwan taiwan which is unusual mostly
are they green or blue
are they are they uh the are they the
the
coleman tang no they they were just
hanging out on farms uh okay so from
southern taiwan probably right my
father's from southern taiwan was from
like a farm near a pond and and then my
mother
so they're taiwan they're deep taiwan
yeah yeah
so
never heard a word about american
politics right in the household never
got any messages being like oh you're
going to do this thing i tell them hey
i'm going to run for president circa
2017 which you can imagine 2017 that's
pretty far out statement because there's
on it's like well he's done some things
but whatever yeah it's a dangerous
business to
to get your status from the achievements
of your kids and i understand it i mean
i'm
very proud of your kids really proud of
my kids i mean they're doing good things
and and and
they're it's very asian by the way but
continue
one of my one of my kids is fujinis
she's the one who's
in some ways most like me
okay and yeah adopted yeah yeah adopted
from uh an orphanage in in fujo
as a matter of fact um she's wonderful
she's in she she after covid made a run
for the border and now she's doing she's
doing college in spain
wow her mother's spanish and so she
speaks spanish but she's like no it's
like i'm i'm a life entrepreneur so this
and and so and i have one who you know
graduated from princeton did really well
and he's he's now he's teaching math
which is his vocation he's bringing the
beautiful the beauty of mathematics to
to young people and i have another son
as a marine i mean they're all just kick
and butt
but if i actually think about getting my
own status from the achievements from
the considerable achievements from the
efforts of my kids it's very easy for me
because they want my they they want my
pride they care what i think about them
for sure it's very easy for them to to
get stuck on their first curve to not be
able to try new things
to be afraid of failing one of the best
ways that you can inculcate if you're a
failure in your own kids is to tell them
i'm so proud of you i'm so proud of the
thing that you're doing because then
they think okay so if i gotta keep doing
this they won't be proud because they're
if look if i hear that hear your parents
don't tell your kids you're proud of
them you gotta be careful with that it's
a really it's a it's to say for one of
the things is to be proud of the right
thing not to say i'm proud of your
achievements to say i'm proud of you i'm
proud of your character maybe say it to
them after they fail because then you'll
be like well you tried and failed to be
like oh good keep doing that yeah yeah
and and for sure particularly if they
failed they failed meritoriously yes if
they fail because they didn't work hard
enough or they were lazy or they cheated
then that's not so i'm really like
really i'm really proud of that failed
bank robbery son i mean that's that's
obviously
not the way to go but there's you know
thinking about the things that we're
talking about in this book and about
this conversation you can deflect those
things onto your kids in in in pretty
destructive ways as well yeah i'm
working on that as a dad my kids are
younger than yours and so i have no idea
if they're going to turn out okay
honestly
someone tells me andrew that they're
going to be fine i don't know well
they're going to go through things it's
interesting you know um one of the
reasons that that people tend to uh get
unhappy or slightly unhappier through
their 40s and until their early 50s is
it these darn kids yeah yeah yeah and so
the kids bring lots and lots adolescent
kids bring lots and lots of meaning but
not a whole lot of enjoyment um i mean
some are different but boy it was tough
i mean it was
it was tricky when my kids were
adolescents to be sure and good news
it it generally speaking turns out okay
i believe
so one of the most powerful messages in
your book uh was that people
end up often uh seeking
a different relationship with religion
or spirituality or faith as they get
older
and it's it's possible i just didn't
know this that i was like do people
um
become more religious as they
uh age
across the board as like a general trend
that's from the book i got the sense
that they do they do generally speaking
and one of the so the empirical
regularity is if you are from a
religious household you'll generally
speak some people will maintain an
enormous amount of religious intensity
over the course of their lives
and they'll they'll go from kid faith to
grown-up faith relatively seamlessly but
a very common pattern is that there's a
lot of questioning in the late teen
years especially in the 20s
and then usually in the late 30s to
early 40s people realize you know life
is
life is really messy and not everything
falls in particular buckets and so i
can't really
reject the existence of god for example
because there's pain in the world
there's lots of contradictions in the
world that are that i can't understand
that i can't resolve and i feel a sense
of the transcendent i feel a sense of
the metaphysical and they go on a faith
journey as a result of that either with
their traditional faith or or a new
faith that they're trying to experience
or even a non-religious spirituality or
even just a philosophy or wisdom
tradition there's a poll generally
speaking to
to zoom out and to find these cosmic
verities you know people really want in
their 40s and 50s in particular to
understand the why of life and the why
of life is simply not going to come by
spending an extra 10 hours a week at
work
it turns out that that's not going away
wait wait wait i've got the source of
meaning i've got it
tick tock buying more stuff on amazon
it's like
no
no that's not getting
a boat i mean that's just that's not it
and and yet people kind of act like it
is but they yearn for something else so
one of the things i talk about you want
to get on your second curve if you want
to go from innovation to wisdom
then one of the things that you need is
is more of a cosmic sense of the why of
life and a spiritual journey is the way
to go it's just it's such an adventure
and by the way it's so
it it gives you so much peace because it
it it encourages you to stop focusing on
me me me me my stuff my job my car my
money my future
it's like you know the dalai lama
i mentioned him a bunch of times in the
book because i've been working with him
pretty closely for the past ten years
he learned the book you know but if you
notice it's the calmest blurb ever it's
like arthur brooks has written a book
about how we age and change
because it's you know it's how a tibetan
buddhist would blurb a book i think but
you know he wrote it then
it wasn't the staff no it was it was his
holiness it's in tibetan
um it's extraordinary you know that but
you know the way that he
the way that he talks about um the
importance of a spiritual journey is to
basically say you need the peace of
understanding you are one of seven
billion and what that means
contemplate that for a second that
doesn't mean you're an ant or you're
insignificant it means that there are
seven billion sisters and brothers that
we are part of a cosmic whole bound
together
obliged and privileged to be bound
together in love
what does that mean well you can't just
know what that means intellectually
that's a that's there's a spiritual
connection there that that's all about
and you can't get that unless you
actually do the work and the work is
intensely pleasurable and satisfying
now i thought that
your lesson there reminded me of
something someone else said i'm just
going to throw this out and then you can
react to it
um said that religion has been lost for
many americans uh that religiosity's
gone down church attendance like a bunch
of they're called the nuns n-o-n-e-s who
classify as having no religion it was
one percent the year i was born and it's
about 34 of americans today
so there's an attendant loss of
meaning community structure purpose
fulfillment and then people are kind of
grasping for something to replace it
and what they're landing on not that
great a lot of the time it turns out
that there was a lot of
wisdom and truth uh and divinity in
traditional
religious
communities and traditions
and one of the suggestions that the
person had which really just you know
made me do a double take but then i
thought had some truth to it was that
what has replaced
religion for many americans is some
combination of political polarization
and even media tribes
where if you consume a certain
media's uh offerings then you you're
kind of joining a cult right and you
know people refer to people who watch
certain channels that cult this cult
that but that really stuck with oh yeah
yeah david foster wallace the great
american writer one time said that
everybody worships something
because people are made to worship we're
just we're just worshipful creatures he
thought that was an innate feature of
humankind and if you take away something
that's worthy of worship you will
replace it with something that's
unworthy of worship it doesn't matter
who you are we all know intellectually
that politics is is unworthy of being
elevated to the level of religion and
yet this is i mean look
your campaign was related to trying to
to de-religiousize
and detribalize uh ideology of political
ideology in this country it's like let's
talk about how to how to bring people
forward and understand each other across
ideological lines well that's basically
like going to people who are extremely
religiously fundamentalist and say make
common cause with this other
group of apostates and heretics you know
what we've done in this country and this
is one of the big problems that we have
is that people are worshiping at the
altar of american politics and their
preachers their tv preachers are on at
seven and eight and nine on cable
channels that's what's going on and and
their favorite columnist at these
important uh uh newspapers who are
saying the things that that they that
they are probably not they're speaking
the gospel yeah they're not the right
gospel
they're saying these what they believe
to be these hard truths and harsh ways
and they want the fundamentalist gospel
because
we need some truth and if we're not
going to actually get it from the from
by doing the the real spiritual work
which and and every good spiritual
tradition by the way completely
militates against these ideas and
teaches something fundamental about the
nature of humanity which is we are all
brothers and sisters with radically
equal dignity fellowship no exceptions
and yet these fake religions that we've
gotten into in this country that are
tearing us apart and by the way making
us miserable like a big date on very
very unhappy the more that's like one of
the empirical regularities that i see in
the data again and again it is a
happiness guy
is that the more time you spend thinking
talking about and reading about politics
the more your happiness will fall it's
so rough man like so i i gave a book
talk the other day um and i said hey who
here has heard of senator lisa murkowski
because she's been the news and then
some people raise their hands and i said
if you
didn't raise your hand congratulations
you're not a political junkie you have a
life and you're probably happier as a
result of it like i got a laugh
people had their hand up or like oh
but i mean it is true like you're paying
attention so this is one reason why
um there there's an argument
conventional politics it's like hey be
engaged be informed uh and then there
are a lot of young people in particular
who are unplugging from it being like
hey
it makes me miserable right it makes me
crazy like you know i'd rather not be
informed
or the rest of it if this is what it
means and one thing i say to people is
like look that's a purely rational
decision they're making at this point
because that like that that's
self-production oh yeah but yeah and
that that's what we've turned politics
into unfortunately yeah totally and so
the the answer is is not to be an
extremist it's it's good to be
involved it's good to be informed um but
let's think about what actually that
means and putting it into action in your
life what does it mean to be a good
citizen
watching a cable channel and getting mad
is not good citizenship you know getting
involved in your community volunteering
at a local organization helping someone
in real life i mean ask the people who
are outraged about whatever the last
national election was or a supreme court
pick or whatever just like out of their
minds on social media
wrapped around the axle in a big way
right or left who won the school board
superintendent election in their
community in the last one they can tell
you they can't tell you i mean this is
there's a lot of new political science
research that shows that this is driving
happiness down but it's also driving
citizenship down this is making it worse
so watching a cable show is not a
substitute for actual citizenship and so
what i recommend to people just as a
rule of thumb
is that you shouldn't read more than 30
minutes of news a day and not more than
half of that should be political news
you can get everything you need to know
about american politics unless you're in
the business unless you're in politics
or policy or something in about 15
minutes a day you're going to know what
you think you're going to know who you
like you know who you agree with and
then put it down there's nothing else
that's going to happen over the course
of this day that should affect your
existence and not more than another 15
minutes so that should be sort of all
the news around you and then pay
attention to your life pay attention to
your relationships
and and you know be involved here be
here now the good old ram das used to
you know he wrote that you know be here
now but that's the essence of living
mindfully to simply notice what's going
on around you and like 100 guaranteed
you'll get happier yeah that there was a
long-term happiness study that you cite
very influential and it had just uh i
think it was seven behaviors yeah that
are more likely to lead to you aging
happily and gracefully and of course i
immediately i'd be a data guy i was like
ooh like let me you know make sure i'm
doing these seven um so we talked about
a couple of them already uh you know
don't drink excessively don't don't
smoke too much
uh actually don't smoke
don't smoke or quit now quit early if
you can yes yeah um
eat in a moderate way exercise don't be
crazy about it but you know take care of
your body uh make sure that you're a
lifelong learner that doesn't mean you
have to be you know go to harvard it
just means you need to read books and
and learn about things ideas not just
politics obviously better not politics
and make sure that you have a good
active coping mechanism but the most the
most the most important of all far and
away on a walk that matters is love
is friendship real friendship
companionate love with your partner if
you have a romantic relationship and
failing that very close friendships i'm
staying close to your nuclear family i
mean tending the garden is really
important i mean there's this famous
scene at the end of you know voltaire's
famous novel candide and at the end you
know they go through all these
adventures in life and it's a metaphor
for all the you know the terrible things
that happen in life and is one thing
after another they're attacked and
kidnapped by pirates and one of them
gets his buttock amputated it's horrible
and at the end they call him only you
know
it's like it's like running for
president anyway so
and at the end um they're like running
for mayor but continued
new york man you chose new york you
should have chosen tacoma washington so
they at the end they're they're at the
end of the novel they're
kind of summing up life
and the main character said the last
line of the book is we just need to
attend our garden
that's it we need a tender garden what
does that mean does that mean cut
yourself off from existence no
pay attention to the actual things that
you can grow pay attention to your
i mean pay attention to the transcendent
and and and worship the divine
absolutely but make sure that your
actions are dedicated to your children
yeah if your mom like i thought when i
was reading this i was like i gotta call
mom
i
this
it's funny that's one of the things i
tell my students is one of the
assignments i give my students is you
know call your parents today yeah really
it's really important and and then the
relationship for young adults to have
with their parents is not like an atm
machine not like an emotional atm
machine where it's like give me counsel
give me money give me help
give me advice yeah it's like call up
mom and say what are you doing today
and actually treat your mom like an
adult i i still remember
the this day uh i got a call from my mom
it was march of a particular year i was
busy i was a teenager late teens i was
annoyed and then um
uh you know i was a bit of a jerk or a
lot of a jerk turns out a huge jerk as
the story will demonstrate
um and then um and then tor at the end
of the call she said andy it's my
birthday you forgot like you know like
uh and and then hung up and then i felt
six inches tall and was like i am the
worst son
in the world i've not forgotten her
birthday sense yeah i'm happy to say
because you can tell that was
uh you know an experience it needed to
teach you a lesson but this is how a lot
of people will wind up people who treat
their family very transactionally
and treat their parents for a
transaction it's just a lost opportunity
it's not just it's not evil or bad it's
just a missed opportunity and and you
know in a lot of cases you know i was
not very
not that close to my my my parents i
mean we were always friendly i was good
but we were i was thought yeah i got to
get closer to my parents got to learn
more about them and then then they died
my parents died young so i thought to
myself well that's a huge missed
opportunity but it isn't because now i
have a completely different kind of
relationship with my adult kids i mean i
learned the lesson that i wish i had
learned with my adult with my aging
parents and and i have a much closer
role i talked to all three of my kids
every single day
and
i'm still interviewing them a little bit
you know
but i had i learned that lesson and
that's actually really quite important
that's one of the lessons of you know
getting older and getting on the second
curve
yes well this book was so filled with
human wisdom i'm going to
uh give it to my brother um because i
think he could use it as well and i
recommend it right he's a professor um
and i this when i was reading this it
very much spoke to me but i was like oh
my my brother needs to read this and if
you know if you have anyone in your life
that resembles someone who's a bit stuck
on an achievement curve or any curve or
isn't tending the garden
from strength to strength is an
incredible read it's so important and it
even gives you seven words to live by
which i'm going to have arthur
deliver i know them too but yeah i'm
reminded because we brought it up in the
conversation but it's the last words
that are worth remembering is
use things
only love people only and worship the
divine only
and if we did those things uh humanity
would be much much better off as a
result thank you so much arthur and this
is a massive contribution thank you
andrew thank you thank you for what
you're doing
[Music]
you